[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
t3m
podcast with your host fayad rami
and angel how's it going today guys
alhamdulillah good morning we got some
we got some messed up weather here in uh
in waterloo what about you guys
i didn't even want to look out this
morning i still don't know
yeah what about you
it could be better
all right so porn
yeah you guys asked for it
we got to deliver all right
is that like the highest here on our
patreon or something
what do you mean by any fans
no bro there's one harder than that
oh yeah the the soundcloud for a little
queasy
yeah all right
but uh before we before we begin though
i got a quick question for you guys
yeah have any of you had any experience
in partaking in the indulging
of adult film videos you mean like
like on the recording end or like
no i don't think okay you know what bro
let's make it open-ended surprised me i
mean i was in 11.
okay that's it yeah
nobody no i'm just playing
i mean i think every dude has partaken
i saw some wrists up in omega last night
not gonna lie
nasty i'm not gonna go in depth man
i can't pretty vulgar nah
stop trying we don't get demonetized
i mean whatever you're gonna do right if
we're not if we're not demonetized by
now i don't know what
that's true that's fair i mean we're not
doing it for the money
thanks yeah um
but yeah some i don't know some dudes
are nasty but speaking of nasty dudes
um you know when i think of porn and men
watching porn and stuff i just
is it not like not not only is it like
shameful but is it not pathetic
it is it is bro think about it like
they're just watching a girl being paid
to do things to another guy that this
man can't get his
his wife or woman to do for him that's
essentially what it is
yeah but something something that's
really crazy is like
it's acting it's all acting and then at
the end of the day like we're paying
money
to watch movies and stream netflix
videos and
on youtube and stuff and like that's
acting too
yeah so some people would go and argue
like well what's the difference it's
acting
well the difference is you're watching
two people
three people four people or one person
get off and then you're getting off to
that which is pretty
pretty messed up if you ask me yeah it's
kind of sad
like you know you know that ad oh my god
i'm not i don't know this ad because
like like it's been a meme it's been a
meme lately
but the eye that's like
you know you're watching but all by
yourself
yeah are you seriously watching porn all
by yourself
yeah and it's like yeah
and make you feel like trash like
imagine
you know whoever you are you're watching
and then that comes up and it's like
you don't stop and think like damn this
is kind of sad
like does it not hit you dude i remember
watching back in the day
and just like ready just ready to like
do the deed finish the business
and then as soon as that ad comes up i
just pause i'm like
damn what am i doing i am alone aren't i
yeah i mean i feel like that those
thoughts would just be
natural because i don't know
isn't it natural for a human to want
their intimate
experiences to be with a person with a
human
and you know like there's a whole idea
of foreplay
and then there's the deed and then
there's like afterwards
and it's like you just do the deed and
there's nobody there and like isn't that
like
lonely pathetic like isn't there like it
is bro but you gotta realize
you gotta realize we live in a society
today where men don't think that
they have what it takes to go get
something
to get the deed man i mean porn doesn't
help
it doesn't bro i was having an
interesting conversation with anno and
i'm sure he'll get into this but
when you're watching porn you're
essentially watching
a girl that you want to get with
obviously because there's a whole
plethora of videos it's not one video or
two videos and
you pick from them but there's a whole
catalog
you literally pick the girl that you
want to get with what's more fascinating
is
you know you can't get with him so
you're watching another guy
do everything that you would have wanted
to do with her
every time the guy gets off to her it's
like you're getting off to that
and it's almost like you're being cucked
it's almost like he's taking your girl
you're a woman yeah and she's
essentially cooking yourself yeah
exactly you're essentially desensitizing
your cuck response
you're getting off to that and then over
time you're happy
doing the deed as rami says without
having gotten with the girl
just by watching another man take your
girl
in a way psychologically that's
essentially what you're doing over time
when you watch
porn so it diminishes your ability to
think that you could be that guy
yeah man we need to start raising some
real men
damn bro it's funny because like i
didn't i was no different growing up
right i was i was honestly i was one of
the worst ones
growing up not necessarily when it comes
to important stuff but when it comes to
you know thinking i can you know get out
there and get this and that like i was
down there right but uh yeah
a self-cooked [ __ ] it's the worst type
that's tough oh and it goes
it goes into the example of
if you're hungry do you eat food or do
you watch people eat food
you eat food right and we're not
speaking
like in terms of haram like oh go out
there
and have sex with a woman but like dude
like
do do what you got to do make it
permissible go get in the car like
get an actual relationship with a woman
yeah
now that's like one topic oh sorry sorry
go ahead go ahead
no no this came in you're speaking i
can't do that i appreciate you letting
me be daddy
all right so the last thing that i want
to say is that when
we do have sex with a woman
we actually release i believe
is oxytocin and correct me if i'm wrong
oxytocin oxytocin there it is
there it is we release that and that's
like
that's like the connection yeah the love
him
it's like it gives us that like sense of
comfort and like connection to the other
person bro
when we're doing it on our own that
doesn't release
we are not getting that release now that
right there in and of itself should tell
you
how unnatural it is to do it by yourself
and how
natural how perfect subhanallah how
perfect it is
to do it with a woman
yeah damn
you ever see a guy like try and use a
tool for something
if you guys are offended at him saying
do it with a woman
go back and watch episode four i mean no
three
episode three that's the one yeah go on
i was gonna say have you guys ever seen
somebody use a tool in a way they're not
supposed to be using it and you're just
like
what the hell is this guy doing imagine
a tool with a tool bro like oh like a
tool you know
and you just like look at him like what
the hell is what's up with this guy
what's he doing
right or like a guy at the gym using a
piece of machinery like completely wrong
like like those guys that do like those
freaking neck ups or whatever 100
i know they're looking down at us bro
and they're like they're like they just
see us just ferociously added bro
and like there's a screen in front of us
and there's nothing behind the screen
it's just like a flat digital screen
and we'll just add it and then we're
just done they're gonna be like bro what
a waste of like human life
exactly exactly um and angela what you
said that's kind of what i was trying to
allude to before but obviously i didn't
know
the terminology or anything or the
scientific aspect to it
but essentially you said what i wanted
to say so thank you
it's like it's it's just unnatural to do
by yourself
but um i was gonna say since we talked
about nikah briefly
i for reasons are not to be mentioned
currently
i was looking into nikah and
i was learning how to you know how to
actually conduct a nikah
and it's so easy allah makes it so easy
you need someone to say a dua
ask do you give the hand in marriage do
you accept and then the maher is to be
determined
maybe put in the contract uh and then
you need two male witnesses who are
practicing to see it
and then congratulations you're done
you're married you are now halal
you went five minutes ago five minutes
ago you were not allowed to touch this
person's hand
and now you can take them home do you
realize how easy
it should be yeah but today we live in a
society where
allah has made halal so easy but society
and culture has made halal extremely
difficult
and haram extremely convenient for
example
let's talk about that oh god
bro i've heard of some girls being
having a matter
which is for those of you that don't
know it's like a dowry that the man pays
wait why are we talking about this so we
talking about pornography
well not both bro and i got some i got
some
some people i know that their bags are
like 100k bro
yeah it's like what that's like pimping
a girl out
it's essentially pimping a girl bro and
and bro allah says
it's sunnah to have them as lowest as
possible
yeah right that's that's what you're
supposed to do not have some like
where they're equating the girl's worth
to the value of the man
that's what you see today bro you guys
then you got then you got wally syndrome
which is like the girl's father or like
whoever is like having like you know
under under his responsibility
he's out here saying no to every other
guy that comes across
even if the girl wants him and it's like
what bro
you know yo you know
you know would be like really really
dope i mean it's probably not ever gonna
happen
but like something that just ran across
my head is like what if
in order to be able to ask for a girl's
hand in marriage
you had to fight the wall-e yo that's
yeah like a wrestling match i was
thinking like actual striking but yeah
wrestling we could do it where it's uh
more a lot and
you know there won't be that much damage
being done but like a wrestling match
and just to see like if you can submit
diwali then
all right you are now you are
invaluable uh there's a word for it
yeah candidate there you go i was also
gonna say that when you ask the question
to us um
is this pornography when they ca i think
they're interrelated because i think
nikah could be a solution to pornography
oh yeah it could be it could be but a
lot of the time
if like if somebody looks to get over a
pornography addiction
with the wife they they've essentially
that's that's the worst
that's like that's like everything
angela was talking about how like
getting in the car everything's done bro
just imagine
fighting a man just to get his daughter
just put yourself through that you get
the daughter
and now you're in the bathroom while the
daughter's in bed
his dad is in bed and you just like add
it by yourself
that's really what makes sense yeah
because like since
like you said before it's an entire
catalog so you're going from an entire
catalog you can see whatever you want
and you know like
how we're all men we know how men get
off right it's not like the way women do
where like we read
like fantasy novels or something like
that like they're more emotional about
it yeah
yeah we we like to see and look and
smell and touch
right so when you have an entire catalog
and you're just watching it
your wife can't keep up with that she
can't be switching out you know hair
hair color and like body type and then
all this stuff like it's just
you can't do that and even if you get
four like that's better that's better
but
is that is that what one sets up this
unrealistic precedence of what
intimacy should be yeah and then
you try to like revolve your whole life
and your actual experiences around that
but that it can't be bro that's not
gonna happen you're gonna you're gonna
set yourself up for failure
every time yeah that's true we should
have like a
a part series just on like intimacy and
like misconceptions brought by the west
and all that we will we will
we will let's believe that because islam
doesn't shy away from intimacy one
one bit yeah yeah matter of fact the
sunnah is so specific it literally talks
about
exactly like the details of which y'all
would not expect
it's always it's only culture that makes
us think that okay we shouldn't talk
about this
we shouldn't we shouldn't tell our boys
about this you know we should hide these
these things about sex and all that bro
at the end of the day
our kids are going to listen and learn
this from someone they're going to find
out about it anyway
yeah it's either going to be us or tom
dick and harry down the street
which are their classmates who are
probably going to tell them some
inappropriate
type of thing that's not really how it
is like oh you're supposed to like bro
there was this kid that told me in grade
six right because like obviously i'm
assuming like you guys
we didn't grow up with like a proper
talk so
there's this kid telling me bro you
gotta put your finger
into the clitoris
do you realize how like bizarre and like
how that's that's not even possible
that's what i got yeah anatomically
speaking
i hope you didn't try that with anyone
man yeah bro uh
no no comment bro no i'm playing i'm
playing
but that's what i mean bro that's it's
pretty it's pretty weird bro it's like
could have been something so easy um and
so simple to just tell a kid but it's
not
it's not the most approachable thing and
i get it bro
but yeah either way there's a lot of men
today growing up with all these
misconceptions
as islam is very specific his son tells
you in the sun i'll tell you to the very
detail what to do what to not do when to
do what
this time of the month it's that time of
the month it's it's super easy bro it's
literally the guidebook or the catalog
or the instruction manual as
brother angel refers to it as right so
anytime you feel like it's a sensitive
topic or you feel a little weird about
it guys
it's not islam it's just your
conditioning your upbringing
how you were raised by your parents how
you were raised by your caregivers
putting this into some taboo category
that shouldn't be talked about
yeah yeah hundred percent and like
the thing is i find myself right with
the sun
we hear a lot of beautiful stories of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi he would
say a very you know
cute kind remark to his wife like she
would ask uh
he she asked once what is your
love like for me and he said like a knot
it's tight
right hard to undo and every once in a
while she would ask how's the knot
how's the not asking like how's your
love for me and that's nice
but people would equate that to being
like an everyday 24 7 thing
but the issue is when you take it like
that it actually falls apart because
there is a balance so
this is the thing we need men who are
men who can teach boys how to be men
and especially when it comes to intimacy
because this is something i shot away
from as well
um and if you read about these things in
the hadith at first you might be like oh
my god what the heck
but then if you were to take this home
and apply it at home
then you'll probably be a lot more
successful which is why a lot of men
aren't successful because they're not
applying these things
and like let's let's be completely real
marriage is important intimacy is like
one of the most important parts of
marriage right
if you're not doing something right in
marriage
where there's a proper way to do it if
you're not doing it right it's going to
fall apart
if you don't know what you're doing what
do you what do you have to do when you
don't know what you're doing you go to
someone who knows even islam
says go to the experts so would it would
it actually be bad or wrong
morally even islamically speaking to go
to somebody
who knows about intimacy and ask
how do i do the whatever and make my
wife happy
would that actually be bad especially if
you go to the quran the sunnah if it's
actually
like quran isn't going to go on death
but if you go to the hadith see what the
prophet
was like is it actually going to be bad
we shouldn't shy away from these things
considering it's literally sunnah allah
literally tells us it's
like you get good deed literally for
sleeping with your wife just for the act
because by definition then you're not
doing the act of adultery
and others pornographies
okay i was gonna say um because i was
basically done
but i want to tie it back into
pornography now
because alhamdulillah we talked about
nika i think we should bring it back to
this inshallah
but we start with pornography and i
think we should just finish off on that
topic because there's something
important we didn't discuss
which are the dangers and the health
issues that arise when a person indulges
in
a lot of pornography damn bro you got
some like personal experience
um yeah i almost lost my arm once doing
it
oh man i almost went blind oh really
damn i heard anaheim almost lost his
hair
i actually did but i lost it all
uncalled for
uncalled i went too far i went too far
bro i lost it all
right man went to the dark side yo i
read somewhere on
a reddit forum when i was like 14 that
not 14 14 or something and it was like
if you if you do the act more than like
six times a day or something
you literally like spew out blood
instead of what you're supposed to do
bro i was doing it 10 to 12 times
minimum a day
um yeah i know we talked about that but
ronnie's romney's gonna be like
like what what did he say
yes what the hell 10 to 12.
that was average
i want to get something out there before
angel talks about that
there's someone that so spends so much
of his time on tick tock which is rami
and someone that's a tick talker watches
tick tocks all day
you carry yourself in such a cohesive
manner
in such a normal manner and everyone i
know that's on tick tock all day
bro they be talking some type of way you
know always talking about the new trend
they don't even talk and sound normal
bro
i mean you you almost threw me under the
bus saying i watched tick tock all day
but uh i don't want all of us you're on
tick tock way more than us
yeah that's fair that's fair that is
fair alhamdulillah
um yeah it is what it is
10 to 12 times a day i don't know man
who's hitting a full set
in a day 12 reps of those not proud
12 reps i don't know if it's 12 reps
though 12 sets bro
12 sets of 3 000.
i mean at least the last sets go gonna
be hypertrophy the first one might have
been strength
last one was probably even endurance and
turns bro all the way
you know you know bro right but real
talk i'm not i'm not proud of that it
was um
yes it was pretty slime it was uh the
weekdays it was
it was before i even got into
self-improvement i didn't know
any better and you know i was i was
hedonistic hedonistic bro
very hedonistic and crazy thing is i had
a girlfriend too
so i was performing the natural
obligation and
doing it 10 to 12 times a day by myself
nah bro i swear on everything bro
i swear on every bro how did you not
have like a electrolyte imbalance
oh i had some kind of imbalance
because i mean once i stopped like a lot
of things changed like physically
the way i looked the way i spoke
everything changed dude and you if no
one believes me they could look at my
own videos
the very very first videos that i made
on my youtube channel
all the way up until like now
there's a huge difference
you talking about the ones with the
cringy intros which ones
those were latin no those were like me
those weren't even beginning those were
made
i found you probably like three years
ago
yeah around around the time you were
talking about like
you know decalcifying your pineal gland
or third eye thing that's crazy bro so
you finally reached out to me after like
two and a half three years ah like a
year and a half
that's crazy though yeah i think i think
you know when you made those videos
about like
feminine energy masculine energy and all
that yeah i think bro i'll be honest
with you just my
as a viewer like strictly speaking like
just someone that watch
watches your videos i would and i still
watch your videos but
my ben i thought that was your not peak
in the sense that you went down after
but bro that was like a highlight for
you like those videos that series you
did
man i was like yo this is it for real
bro i was about to get
those nah bro there's so much value in
that
it's good man like you watch that video
you watch episode one and you're like yo
that's not someone that
would partake in solo runs 12 times a
day
solar runs oh oh okay yeah yeah yeah
you watch that video it's like nah bro
this guy
you know this does not do that for sure
100
yeah yeah you're right you right but um
yeah so the negative implications
of pornography what do you guys think
about that
what have you all experienced because i
know i know damn
that at some point before you guys got
real serious
in the dean you probably may have
that with a little bit in that so what
did y'all experience
okay bro so there's three different
categories so one is gonna be
physical one is gonna be mental and
one's gonna be
spiritual or like with your soul you
know this
most people aren't gonna really have a
good connection with regarding porn so
they won't really understand but
let's start with physicals so with me i
haven't noticed any of the physical
symptoms
i do know well for me it was more like
psychological
but i know a lot of people had physical
symptoms like they had
they couldn't get it up or they were
busting too quick
or they had problems with uh you know
just blood flow so
romney do you have anything like that or
have you had any experience with that
um not really but i do remember
um the way of life sq i think his name
is
yeah right yeah yeah in that video that
you said he was talking about
when you're you know when you're doing
that you're damaging the nerve endings
because it's not
you know built for your the palm of your
hand or something and no matter what you
use
to you know make it smoother or easier
like you're still damaging the nerve
endings
so that's one physical implication
negative physical implication that i
think should be you know
taken into account because even like
even
as somebody who doesn't really
masturbate when i heard that i got
scared still and it's like damn
like that's the scary thing because if
somebody's doing that often because
yeah someone does often it's like that's
messed up because
it could lead to i mean it's just normal
to think about what it could lead to if
you're damaging the nerve endings if
you don't have the nerves then you're
not going to feel and if you don't feel
then
you're done 100 man you're literally
desensitizing yourself
to your your hand which isn't gonna feel
like some
some sugar walls bro let me be honest so
when you do that
it's gonna be like okay well i don't
feel the same so why don't i feel the
same
so then you'd rather prefer that solo
run than being with the girl
which is not it's not the way
about boy yeah yeah
so you know if i had you said
psychologically you
you experienced something from it would
you experience psychologically
one thing before we wrap up physical so
with physical
most of our viewers i'm assuming are
muslim so i'm just gonna take a
take a long shot i'm assuming most of us
because we're muslim
we're also circumcised but those of you
that don't know
bro a circumcision literally makes your
sensitivity
go down by a thousand fold because it's
literally you're taking off the most
sensitive parts
of your body i'm not going to talk about
you know
implications or or should this be called
general mutilation or whatnot but
the reason we do it is so it helps us
not be
so instinctive and so primitive
and not just fully rely on our desires
and impulses
but so yeah that was more for like
hygiene
well yeah there's hygiene aspect too but
with everything there's hydrogen in
islam
right but we'll talk about that too but
with that
if you're a circumcised guy watching
this you know
trust and believe the sensitivity you
feel right now
would be a thousand fold
higher if you were not circumcised so
just picture this you're already one
thousandth
of your sensitivity now as rami said
if you partake in this you're gonna be
desensitizing yourself even further
let's say you're gonna be like one in
ten thousand
of the circ of the sensitivity like bro
you you're soon not even gonna be able
to like perform
that's it's ridiculous yeah it's
essentially like setting themselves up
for
failure once they actually get you know
with a woman because they're used to
this this this this this and then when
they get there it's kind of like
i didn't do my readings it's literally
it's it's literally pavlovian
conditioning there's nothing different
the stimuli is pornography the
response the conditioned response is
gonna be you getting off
and when you don't have that stimuli
again you're not gonna be able to get
off because you're gonna have a real
girl
who i'm sure no man would disagree is
much better but you're not gonna know
what to do with it
because even though like physically
you're there psychologically your
brain's not forming the association
between that cue and getting you off so
it's now like a foreign object you're
like okay what do i do with that
you might be you might be trying to get
down but it's not going to work so
it's kind of redundant at that point but
to address angel's
question about psychological things i've
noticed personally
the first biggest thing i've noticed is
over time
i start i start like losing this this
drive this like
this psychological thing in my head this
mental state
so like just go get it just go out there
right because
as a man i feel like and this might be
some freudian perspective but freud says
that
um you know our whole drive is pleasure
right it's like the pleasure principle
so as men
my whole goal is to just procreate how
are you going to have that drive to go
procreate
and go bust that nut if you know you
could just do it at your house
if you know you could just do it behind
closed doors when no one's watching
you feel me yeah so it's like bro it
really makes no sense
to me yeah um i feel like on a primitive
level
on an instinctual level um yeah that
would be true but at the same time our
humans right we are people with
when you said drive i thought you meant
like motivation and drive because with
me it's like
i became a lot less driven and motivated
in life
and when you compare that to something
like working out
even after a full day of working out you
feel even more driven
you feel even more motivated even though
you've just done an entire workout and
you should feel out of it
me personally it's it's even more
motivating
i want to go back but when it's the
opposite when you're like masturbating
or watching porn or something
one it's shapeful two it's a waste of
time three doesn't have any good well
people would say would have good
benefits but i would say the bad heavily
heavily outweigh the good but yeah you
have
horrible implications and then
afterwards
afterwards you're not even motivated to
do anything other than that again
[Music]
there's a there's a study and i'm gonna
have to link it now that i'm bringing it
up
yeah but in the study they uh basically
test
to see uh the whole
theory on like oh you have to release
in order to not have prostate cancer
right that's that's what people say and
doctors will specifically say oh you
need to release at least
once a week or uh once every two weeks
or something like that so you don't have
prostate cancer but it
dude number one the body takes care of
itself
all right if you do not release your
body is gonna take care of yourself
you'll probably
have a wet dream or you'll probably
release internally or something like
that look into it yourself
but in the study bro they actually found
that
at a younger age i want to say it was
from like 20
to 30 something i'm butchering it i'm
gonna have to link it
in the description box but from the
younger age
if you busted more frequently you
actually had a higher chance
of getting prostate cancer and at an
older age
after 50 something that's when busting
more frequently
actually lowered your chances of getting
prostate cancer
so that's something to take into
consideration crazy you know what else i
want you to
tap into is those things you were
talking about no fap and how
your testosterone diminishes a couple
days or something like that
tell us about that yeah yeah so
[Music]
when you do nofap you you bro it doesn't
really increase testosterone like how
many people think it does it's
i think it's every seventh or eighth day
you'll have a spike
in your testosterone levels and that's
like
after you stop busting like let's say
you busted let's say you were
having sex with your wife and you
obviously
you found the natural obligation you
released
bro if you didn't release again by the
seventh eighth day you would have a
spike in your testosterone
which is bro a hundred percent useful
for working out and building muscle and
building strength but it's only for that
day and then after that it just goes
right back to normal
so like if someone isn't is experiencing
an increase
in testosterone because they're going on
nofap like exponentially
well that just means that they had a
deficiency
in uh micronutrients because every time
you release you're actually releasing
key vital nutrients like zinc potassium
and magnesium magnesium there's other
ones for sure
which we'll have to link now that we're
seeing me as well but
y'all get the picture
yeah man that's that's crazy
all right so is that it for
psychological do you want to talk about
spiritual because i feel like i have
bro i feel like i feel like there's more
with psychological i feel like there's
confidence issues too
which a lot of people don't talk about
where it's like the day after
you do it and this is just me bro
i'm not gonna speak on behalf of anyone
else i would notice that
i'm not gonna be like unconfident i have
low self-esteem but i'm more
self-conscious about things that i
wouldn't be self-conscious otherwise of
like i wouldn't just be in a flow state
where i know i'm the best version of
myself and i'm just attacking the world
i would be more okay how am i attacking
the world how do i look coming across
this or that vice versa and i know i
wouldn't be doing that when i'm on no
fap
and when i'm not masturbating and all
that do you guys have any like can you
relate with that
yeah it makes you stuck in your head
because it has to do with dopamine
and again if i can find if i can find a
study on this
i will for sure link it but you got to
understand
everything in this life releases
dopamine to a certain extent but when
you watch pornography
that's releasing an unnatural like an
out of this world unnatural amount of
doping because bro we were made
for one woman at a time and you know
like
not god forbid i'm not saying this in
like that this is a lie but
there's some people out there that do
more than one woman at a time but even
then you're not gonna have
16 17 20 plus women available to you
at once to your liking you're just
cycling through whichever one you want
bro that's what pornography does it
releases way too much dopamine
bro what ends up happening is your body
tries to
maintain homeostasis an even level
of neurotransmitters now if you're the
neurotransmitter off the rib you got
dopamine you got acetylcholine you've
got
no no not norepinephrine or maybe
norepinephrine i might be saying
that wrong serotonin gaba um
definitely have to link these as well
damn too much linking man
but um anyways you have this level your
body tries to have this homeostasis
right when you watch pornography
your dopamine is going all the way up
here
way too high it's not normal it's not
natural so your body is like
ah like we have to do everything
possible
to bring this back down
so naturally the dopamine will drop but
your body is seeing a huge
imbalance and is going to try to correct
this imbalance and when it tries to
correct the imbalance
after a few days your new base level for
everything else
rises a bit but then the dopamine drops
all the way to the bottom
and then now you have all your other
neurotransmitters up here
and then your dopamine instead of being
all the way up there it's all the way
down here and that
explains why you feel more stuck in your
head
why you feel less confident while you
feel more anxious
yeah so what do you say would have like
social anxiety
or don't understand would produce social
anxiety okay because i was gonna say
i it's not something i'm really going
off of in terms of study or personal
experience but i feel like a lot of men
who indulge in that frequently would
have a harder time
speaking to a woman in real life because
their only experience with women
is on the screen and them by themselves
no communication no game nothing
bro before announce goes in think about
it you're literally out here
getting the one thing you're supposed to
get getting a girl talking to her
you know building that attraction
building that report
you know obviously permissibly and then
doing the deed
you're getting that doing nothing you're
getting that clicking buttons or tapping
screens
yeah which really don't take effort bro
it's like imagine if i could just tell
you
to like keep tapping your phone just
like watching porn and watch workout
videos
and then you're gonna get jacked like
imagine how easy it would be bro
it's not it doesn't work like that
but that's that's what we live in y'all
that is what we live in and
to end off with the uh physical and
psychological
right physical like we said you're
releasing a lot of
key vital micronutrients
so if you're doing it all the time it
would make sense that it would affect
you
on a physical level and then
psychologically like we said dopamine it
is
basically disrupting the natural balance
of your neurotransmitter levels yo one
more thing too for physical
you gonna be in pencil mode bro pencil
mode
yeah what you mean pencil
if you don't get it now you'll get it
later when you watch back on this trust
me bro
i'm speaking on performance bro you're
going to be in pencil mode
oh limp 100 not just limp like you're
just
you're not there bro you're not in full
like you're not ready bro you're not at
your max you're not at your best
it's true it's very true erectile
dysfunction
that is something that happens to a lot
of people watching pornography
erectile dysfunction and it makes sense
i mean
let's be honest guys when someone does
begin to
do this when someone does begin to watch
pornography
they get into some nasty stuff
and it's not it's not their fault bro
it's not it's not their fault it's not
it's not even our fault it's it's just
the way we are bro it's called the
coolidge effect
where they have this study damn dude
here i go i'm gonna have to link another
study
but um there's a study with the rooster
and they put a chicken in and chicken is
a female
right so they put a chicken in there and
the rooster gets it in with the chicken
but then after he's done he does the
natural obligation he's
well he doesn't want to do anything with
this chicken anymore they removed that
chicken they put another chicken oh
boy he's ready he's ready for round two
like it was
nothing bro and he'll keep doing that
he'll get to like round 10
round 12 and he'll still keep going
he'll still keep going bro
and that's what the coolidge effect is
that we always go for something more
it's like when someone
is addicted to a drug they have to do
more and more of that drug to have the
same
effect right so pornography man like
people get into it and they start
getting into some
nasty stuff bro now imagine imagine
you're watching this
nasty stuff and then you're going
to have sex with your with your wife
with your girl
bro it would be a no-brainer that you
would experience
erectile dysfunction because you are
literally programming yourself to be
aroused to this nasty stuff and a normal
woman just doesn't do it
all right so what do you what do you
prescribe to somebody full-on dopamine
detox
that's a start for sure but like bro it
goes
way way deeper than that if you're
trying to quit
let's talk about the um the spiritual
aspect
all right listen that the spiritual
aspect firstly i want to say that for
muslims if anybody
knows it's a sin and then does it you're
going to experience cognitive dissonance
that's on a mental level
it won't apply to everyone if they don't
think it's a sin if they don't think
it's wrong but it will have the negative
implications regardless
spiritually however the apostle is
in the hadith that when a person when a
muslim sins
a black dot is put into their heart and
the more they send the more black dots
to put into their heart until their
heart becomes like a black coal it's
just black
and that's like dead right and to revive
it and when you do i believe when you do
a good deed
a white dot is put on it and you need to
do is forgive you and make tawba repent
to allah
to cleanse your heart and to feel whole
again
and when you're doing something you know
as a sin
what it does is it regresses your
spiritual state and it regresses your
connection with allah
the best of deeds that allah loves are
those which he made obligatory
so what allah makes for you must do it
brings you closest to him it's the best
deeds to bring you close to him
so imagine now what allah has made
forbidden
imagine how far back you're putting
yourself in terms of your connection
with allah
when you're doing something this vulgar
this damaging
on a daily basis multiple times a day
imagine how bad and how regressive your
spiritual state is going to
get and how far back it's going to
diminish
dude alhamdulillah man imagine how i was
10 to 12 times a day like i must have
been
i don't know bro but i
but that's the thing because allah is so
merciful and i think talking about a
spiritual aspect you have to mention
this always
allah is so merciful he says
he says tell my servants who have
transgressed and harmed themselves by
committing sins
don't despair don't lose hope in the
mercy of allah in allah
indeed allah forgives all sins and it is
him who is the most forgiving and the
most merciful
so if you fall into this let's say you
do this three times a day every day for
the rest of your life
but on the last day of your life you
don't know you're going to die but on
the last day
you say you know what i regret
everything i did and i want to start new
you repent for what you've done
everything allah will forgive you if
you're sincere allah will forgive you
and if you die in that state then what's
to stop you from going to jannah allah
makes it so easy to come back allah says
if you walk to me
i will run to you if you go a hand span
allah will go an arm spent to you
how beautiful is that so with all this
being said
the most important i would say is a
spiritual aspect
because let's say you have no physical
health and even if you lose your mental
health
as long as you have the connection with
allah as long as you're not insane
because an insane person doesn't get
sins but as long as
you know you you are capable of having
that spiritual connection with allah
you're good that's literally all you
need
that's literally all you need so take
care of that first and once that is set
it's like think about it as the core
right the spirit is like the core of you
and who you are and then from there goes
the mental and physical
so start there make sure it's solid
that's why allah revealed heaven and
hell first
and not do this do that do this do that
and all these mental applications
or these like don't do this physically
right there is a spiritual aspect first
get that right and insha allah the rest
of you will be right
i mean
a little bit there but dude i feel like
no you're good bro
preach preach man i feel like i did
the complete opposite like instead of
getting the spiritual right
first like i got the physical
and the psychological right first and it
wasn't until
it wasn't until i'm not gonna say
recently because recently it's like when
it finally like cemented 100 once i came
to islam but like before because i
already told you guys like
i started coming back to god i want to
say like
in maybe 2016 2017.
so it it's been a while but
once i started to come back together
that's when it kind of like
started making the whole process the
whole journey of trying to quit
a lot easier because beforehand it's
like
dude exactly what you said when you
perform a scene like
it puts a stain on your heart it puts
that little black dot and it's like
it just makes you cold it makes you
disconnected and makes you unconscious
of what's happening you know i'm like
bro that's exactly how i can explain it
like
when i was in that state doing it so
many times a day bro
not only was i atheist but like there
was
bro there was no way on earth
that i was going to feel god to feel any
connection whatsoever
in that state because i i was literally
engaging in it every single day that i
was
disconnecting myself so much bro
not only was i disconnecting myself from
the creator but i was disconnecting
myself from myself
bro i didn't even know who i was i i was
just
ridiculously anxious i i don't know but
i was like
i was like a show of what i am today
to be honest and like i said
alhamdulillah i think a lot of people
will be able to find benefit in that
inshallah
so may allah bless you and one thing i
want to clear up is when i say get the
spiritual light fir right first i'm
speaking to the muslims
the muslim people because an atheist or
somebody who's
not muslim or someone who's not
religious or spiritual in any way
may not has no reason to believe that
they even have a spirit
to them it's just fundamental but the
thing is
if a person we talked about you know um
going off of what you observe
inductively and trying to get your
mental and spiritual right in terms of
life your morality and all that we talk
about how difficult that is but if a
person manages to get on the right path
eventually they actually line up with
islam right
so their spiritual so specially they go
up as well because of that
because that's just the proper way of
living and then when the person
this is why a lot of people in in like
in uh
what you're in like the self motivation
and self improvement and all that
in that realm which is basically kind of
like who
we're trying to become who are targeting
here because it's so real
right they're so real and then when they
come to islam they realize how real it
is
just like all three of us did
alhamdulillah so
when you're when your mental is right
when you write mentally
it lines up with islam and i mean this
is something you probably experienced
firsthand
you just actually i think i think all
three of us experience this because we
would do something
which is islamically wrong not
understanding why it's wrong then we
would go back and be like that's why
islam says it's wrong
and not only that but islam adds this
this and that and now i can see the
implications and
so on and so forth but we'll go more
deep into that another day but
yeah subhanallah yeah
you guys got anything else you want to
say well hold up how did both of y'all
feel
when y'all were doing
the thing and y'all were muslim
i didn't feel disconnected did you feel
disconnected no because growing up
i wasn't taught islam the right way and
it's no one's fault this is what it is
and because of that i was i'm growing up
in in
a religion where i wasn't even taught
that bro this is literally
the truth the word of god i was thought
of it as
oh we're muslim and they're christian
and they're jew
like it's it's it's just something it's
like a color you know
not it's like just one of many you could
be any but it wasn't taught to me like
yo
you
are muslim you are all muslim like you
are of the religion
the only real religion well we're not
gonna get into that
i wonder how your mom's gonna feel if
she watches this
she is gonna watch this bro and she
knows this but at the end of the day
it's no hard feelings there's no hate
right yeah
yes but here's the thing she didn't
teach it to me that way because she
wasn't taught it that way
and her mama didn't teach it that way
her mama didn't teach it that way but
it goes back as far as you wanted to but
bro that's now that you're not there the
point is it has to end somewhere
if not now that when you feel me but
with that being all said
um wasn't really taught it the right way
in the sense that okay yo the value the
gift of the song
right it was just like oh here's we're
of this
kind of creed and when you're in this
creed you do this you don't you don't do
that and if you do this these are the
consequences right
so i'm just like okay whatever bro rolls
rolls rolls
combine that with growing up in a
society where i wasn't taught about
masturbation or porn or any of this so
what i learned from my friends who made
it feel like
it's weird if you're not masturbating
the porn every day
or two times a day six times a day so
you know we
and bro i grew up in like this ghetto
ass area bro
and like we would have the school bus
that took us to school
and it's like a 30 40 minute drive
almost an hour both ways
and these were the people that i was
surrounding myself with because this was
the average kid
so you could imagine two hours a day
a couple years what's what's
probably going through a kid's head so
i'm out here like
just doing the d bro not really feeling
some type of way but then it's like
i don't really think that's that's
limited to pornography i think that's
limited to
anything everything i think that's
limited to all sins as a muslim
if you don't understand the gift and
value of islam
you're not going to feel some type of
way doing sins
you're just going to do them you're not
going to understand the value behind it
the wisdom behind it
yeah you might come across some like
scientific
secularism type of understanding of why
the prescription has been ordained for
us like
if you're not religious but you're like
oh
now i see why muslims fast because of
autophagy or because of cellular
cleansing or because of human growth
hormone or testosterone
or mental clarity right but it's like
you're still going to come to the truth
somehow whether it's secularism science
astrology anything whatever you want to
say you're going to come to it
regardless but allah has already set
that instruction manual plain and simple
yeah either you're going to come across
it on your own accord somehow in 10
years or you could just look at it and
come across it now
the choice is yours yo rodney before you
go
once you're done y'all remind me because
bro this is one thing that i want to say
that's
going to link all of this together and
it all relates back to what rami said in
the beginning so rami go ahead bro
all right it's going to come first false
are coming shall allah yes sir
all right so yeah just to pick you back
off what you were saying um
well first to answer the question i
think a better way for me to answer it
would be um
there is a brother named abu makka on
instagram and tiktok and he made a skit
where he showed basically
you know a young man who goes and they
masturbate and they mess up
they're muslim they know what's wrong
they feel shameful they regret it they
go
they make hustle they shower and clean
themselves they pray ask allah to
forgive them they repent
and they're doing good they're doing
good for three weeks or so and then they
fall back into it
and they feel shameful and then they go
and repent again
and this is the cycle of a muslim
whether it's pornography alcohol or
whatever it is no matter what it is any
sin this is the cycle of a muslim and
this is actually normal
you mess up you ask for forgiveness you
mess up you ask for forgiveness and
allah says or the prophet
said that if allah if humans didn't
commit sins he
allah would destroy us and replace us
with the creation that sinned and
repented
so it's normal it's normal i'm not
saying it's normal to masturbate but i'm
saying it's normal to
slip and mess up feel the shame shame is
a beautiful thing
because there's actually um i believe it
might be a hadith of the prophet saws
but there was one sheikh
where a very shameless man came to him
and he stopped him in the middle of his
travels when everybody was around him
and he's like who are you and he's like
i'm a person who narrates you know
hadith and gives it to certain people
and this is the man with a
bottle of alcohol in his hand right out
in the open and back then it was a very
nobody did this except for shameful
shameful people and he
he said give me something then give me
something for me and he said
those who have no shame can do anything
they want
because they have nothing to stop them
from doing shameful things
very profound and this actually this man
ended up becoming an amazing scholar of
islam afterwards
but i just wanted to summarize it with
that it's
you feel the shame but it's actually
good because the shame
is like stress in a way the stress is
what pushes you to study or workout or
whatever you need to do it
pushes you to get things done shame
pushes you to get repentance done
alhamdulillah i'm fine can you remind me
of one of your last points
because being taught islam the right way
that having to do with
seeing sins for sins yeah
that's the last thing i talked about i
had a good point on that but it slipped
my mind now man add that to the list
this is like the 17th time i said that
or something
yeah another thing i wanted to i wanted
to make sure it goes on
this rip um there's a lot of brothers
that can relate to me a lot of sisters
too
and at the end of the day this is a
message to the youth too
you gotta forgive your parents
if they messed up or slipped it's human
all right not just in the sense of
teaching you islam
but anything because at the end of the
day whatever they did
was their idea and definition of their
best
foot forward it might not have been
objectively
truthfully speaking but it's their
definition of it nonetheless
and i just be honest bro islam doesn't
just tell us to respect our parents
because without them you wouldn't be
here like physically you wouldn't be
here
um like biologically speaking but
genuinely bro you wouldn't be where you
are today without them
like you came into this world through
allah
you know your parents were the the
medium i guess you could say
the channel and then they literally made
you into the man or woman you are today
watching this video so a lot of people
don't even have that blessing
right you're out here taking your
parents for granted where someone else
who
lost a parent or both worse yet
would give an arm and a leg to see them
again and be with them one more time
right just once so tremendous
you know respect goes out to everyone's
parents and
at the end of the day bro if they didn't
teach you a song properly it's probably
because they weren't taught properly too
they were ignorant they weren't really
believers and it's because they weren't
all right
and what's worse is this was already the
father of allah
this was already allah's plan because
allah guides who he wills
when he wills so you can't take anything
personally from anyone because
it was all decreed upon by the creator
by the source
yeah so if you do feel that calling come
to you
and this also goes to my brothers and
sisters who are not muslim yet because
we got a lot of comments
down below on the videos saying oh i'm
christian but i kind of feel this
compulsion now i'm kind of intrigued
into this now i'm kind of interested
into this topic now
if you do feel that bro it's from the
source islam isn't some religion where
it's like
some arab god or something like that no
bro allah is literally god
there is one god we believe in the same
thing that everyone else believes in if
they believe in one god
it just tells you here's what to do and
here's what not to do so if you feel
that connection to
allah to god to the source and it's a
one-on-one it's not between anyone else
it's between you
and allah and you feel it pulling you
into islam
don't shy away from it come into it with
an empty empty mind come into it with no
preconceived notions with an empty club
as angel says and you'll be surprised
where you end up
yes subhan
this is why it's so important
for everybody to not rely on blind faith
growing up in a household that is muslim
and saying you're muslim that is blind
faith if you don't have reason to
believe in it that is blind faith
and islam actually says that there are
four ways to believe in something
there are two which are right two which
are wrong so one is the fitzra
innate belief that is fine right innate
belief in god that is fine
two is logical rational reason to
believe in it that is also fine
the third is um blind faith and
the fourth i think i think it was
something like growing up
just being taught that which could also
be blind faith
yeah so it's the most
important i would say to logically
rationally believe in it because if you
don't have reason to believe in
something then why would you believe in
it
and it's going to create all this
unnecessary all these unless necessary
problems
with your faith and
this is why people should convince
themselves logically rationally using
the arguments we gave
in the first video that god exists
and once you have that why islam is true
the quran the prophet muhammad
there's so much evidence to prove it to
literally prove it to you
get that and then you'll have no reason
to doubt anything in the quran
and once you have no reason to doubt
anything in the quran when allah says to
avoid certain things
you no longer need a scientific secular
reason because the one who knows
everything with no bias is telling you
what's correct
you know it's correct therefore you will
accept it imagine if you like everybody
has thought once in their life what if i
had
like a computer or a magic eight ball or
some kind of magic
tool device where i could ask any
question and get the perfect answer what
should i do in the situation what should
i do in that situation
that as muslims is what we have not on
every single like specific level
but on a very vast and general basis
we have those answers and if you believe
in allah and you believe the quran is
the word of god
and the prophet muhammad saw the
messenger then take that
and by default you'll be good in life
this alhamdulillah man i mean brother
like there's specific prayers we could
do
that we literally pray for guidance from
allah in decision making
and i haven't heard about it until
recently but i've been practicing this
for
years bro anytime i'm like okay should i
get this card should i do this should i
make that decision should i apply to
this program
i don't just do it because i'm at a fork
in the road so what i do is i just pray
to allah for guidance
bro every single time i've made a major
decision that
really turned out beneficial to me in
the long run it's because in that moment
allah made it like
easy for me if i sensed after praying
that allah gave me some type of
resistance
like it didn't work out or it wasn't
available or something happened or i
didn't make it
i didn't fight it i didn't go against
the grain i didn't make that uphill
battle
striving towards it by force because i
realized
it's going against the the natural
obligation of allah's commandments
so i was like screw it
you're talking about istahara right
i know you had a point bro before we
went off on this
wrap it up man yeah
oh am i am i a part now i can speak
listen i don't need y'all's permission
all right but to tie in this whole thing
that we're talking about
if i had the last point or the thing
that you said before you interrupted me
it was good it was good it would
definitely helped bring this point
home even more so rami said in the
beginning
that we need to raise actual men
in today's society right and then you
started saying that um you have to
forgive your parents
because they were just doing what they
knew best
and unfortunately they didn't they
didn't do
exactly what was supposed to be done all
right so yes
forgive your parents but at the end of
the day like
it's your father's fault now i'm not
saying like throw the blame card here
i'm saying
your father was the one that was
supposed to show you
the way show you how to be a muslim show
you how to be a real man
show you what it is that you do when you
are with a woman
and guys i speak for myself my father
didn't do that for me
a lot of dudes fathers out here they
didn't do that for them and bro they
could be great people the fathers could
be great people
but it's just they didn't do what was
necessary and
that's where the responsibility now
falls into our hands
and we have to be the ones to
self-improve become the best version of
ourselves
and then once we have kids to be able to
be
that father that we needed while we were
growing up
and that ties all this in together
because let's be honest
if we had a real strong father that was
showing us the way
and literally there for us for
everything
we probably wouldn't have watched
pornography we probably would have never
got into pornography
we probably would be a lot further in
terms of
our progress whether that be
self-improvement
whether that be in our dean whether that
be
financially speaking whatever it is we
will be
miles ahead now i know a lot was what he
was and allah's plan is about his plan
but
being real like the responsibility is in
our hands now
yeah 100 100
man and yeah at the end of the day like
it makes me wonder sometimes too like
let's say you're growing up with the
father that didn't teach you right
yeah it's his fault not to pin the blame
on him but he probably wasn't taught
right by his father
right and it's like you could go as deep
as you wanted to but at the end of the
day
something happened is angel's saying
where it's like you're no longer that
missing link anymore
it's like you are that person in that
chain of
heredity in that chain of paternity
where it's like you're now
in charge you have to break it now
yeah 100 and it's like if you already
feel that cool like i'm different than
my forefathers i'm different than my
ancestors i'm different than my
previous predecessors generations and
you want to be that guy what's stopping
you
literally what is stopping you if you're
around people that's making it hard for
you to become that person
cut them out bro like imagine just not
praying salah or not being
a muslim or doing what you think is
right because you're afraid of what
people are gonna say
you're literally putting off allah god
the creator's
commandments for you because of what
people might say
or gossip about you like makes no sense
to me
right so whether that be your beliefs
whether that be your values
if you feel like you want to raise a
strong guy and society's telling you nah
you should let them do this you should
let them that
why would you listen to them as if they
know
anything that's better do what you want
to do provided is resourceful and
valuable
you guys know what i'm talking about bro
and let me jump in here let me jump in
you guys so
the in hinduism they refer to this thing
as karma
you guys have heard of it i'm sure
everyone's probably heard of karma
right well when i was actually into that
a while back i looked
i like really really delved into it in
terms of the whole karma aspect
and you got to think about it like this
when you procreate with a woman
you are passing your genes on to this
child this child is now
a replica of you and the woman who you
procreated with who you had sex with
right you are passing your genes your
is it which chromosomes do we pass on
we pass on both x or y x x y and then
the women is only the
the next yeah yeah so not only are we
passing that down
but in those genes in those chromosomes
is
everything all the genetic information
all of our history our actions our
experiences
everything is all plugged into those
genes
those chromosomes so bro let's say you
have an addiction
to pornography and you have a kid bro
that kid is now predisposed bro that is
basically karma in a realistic
explanation
so it's like now that kid has to carry
that on
bro it's it's crazy man it's
nah man you you're right you're right
bro is this thing called karmic debt
and what karmic debt is is like let's
say you murder someone
which is a sin just like pornography as
brotherhood mentioned and you unresolve
it
unresolved means you you know repent for
it make it right fix your world ways
you pass on to that to your offspring
that same karmic debt
and and i think in buddhism they talk
about how you need to like
resolve the karmic debt or you get the
consequences for your ancestors actions
yeah that's what it is bro that's all it
is so fix yourself
fix the flaws of your forefathers of
your ancestors of bringing
fix the flaws in yourself we're not
perfect but it doesn't make you
it doesn't make it any sense for just
give up and be like okay we're never
gonna be perfect anyway
but fix yourself now then later and that
way you're giving your offspring
literally energetically speaking
no karmic debt they're literally
starting fresh
clean slate and combine that with you
being a proper strong father
oh man they're gonna have everything you
didn't have
if i can if i can jump in here quickly i
mean as muslims we don't believe in
karma necessarily right we don't believe
in karma and
this idea of like because the christians
have a similar idea of original sin
right adam and eve originally sinned and
that was passed on to every single
person through their father um that's
why they see
jesus as sinless because he didn't have
a biological father therefore the sin
did not apply to him because it was
given down paternally
so i don't want to fall into any like
bid or like
innovation like that so on like a
scientific level of like genetically
inheriting certain traits um which
manifest
psychologically or by other means in the
way you behave and the way you
think the way you're prone to certain
things that's fine that's fine but i
just want to make it clear though we
don't actually believe in karma
or you know karmic dick
karmic debt or anything like that but we
say in the sense that
they started the cycle of messing up and
it's not your fault
but it is now your responsibility mm-hmm
like there's no
physical karmic energy it's just like
they messed up in
this one practice they would indulge in
or this one thing they would do
therefore they taught you that and
because of that you do that
not because like there's something like
a magical spiritual thing like you're
talking about alcoholism
it could be behavioral where you grew up
around your mom drinking a lot and she
was an alcoholic so you're like okay
cool
it's normalized to you and then you
become an alcoholic nah okay i got it
yeah it's on you
to stop that but what's worse is
you have it easy you're you're exposed
around her drinking
24 7 and you can stop that what's worse
is some people there's this thing called
fetal alcohol syndrome
where it's literally a genetic thing
where a mom would drink when
the kid was in the fetus was in the womb
and now they literally have a physical
dependence to alcohol
it's the same thing with weed and all
that so it's crazy man
yeah it's a panel so are you speaking in
the sense that if you guide a person to
good
you also get a share of good and if you
got a person to bad
then you would also get a sin if they
indulge in it because you've brought it
to them
yeah but more so like guide yourself
first
yeah you can't guide yourself how are
you gonna guide others
right a lot a lot tells and then like
people have this messed up priority
nowadays too
might go on a tangent but it's like
people are out here trying to save
everyone
i'm not saying not to save everyone but
i'm saying save yourself first because
if you can't save yourself first how are
you going to save everyone else
how are you going to be the best version
for your wife for your kids for your
family
if you can't even put yourself first i
want to die for my kids
bro how are you kids going to survive if
you die for your kids
that is true you got to be the best so
you could save everyone and give them
the best
yeah i was watching a podcast with the
saint in the center and
one of the guys he said they're talking
about purpose in life and you know that
stuff and how you have to give a woman
purpose and all that
and it sounds unrelated but basically
the guy said you can't give what you
don't have
and that's essentially what you're
saying here you right you want to give
salvation you want to give the truth you
want to give the guidance
how the hell are you going to give that
if you're broke yourself right if you
don't have it yourself
it's like you're poor and i'm like here
let me give you five dollars and i'm
poor
i'm just as poor as you how the hell am
i gonna give you five dollars it doesn't
make sense
but if you have the wisdom if you have
the guidance we have the knowledge if
you have that character
that's why we learn from the best of the
best
because he had these things he
implemented these things he was the best
of examples
he was the best example of a human being
that's why we take from him
so you know what i want to say to all
the the brothers out there because i
feel like we're all
in the same boat of not really having
that father figure
right look to the prophet salallahu he
was the best man
and i promise you i promise you if i
didn't have him
as a role model even if it's just in
like hadith and narrations
i would be completely different i would
be like off the walls
i would be messed up so alhamdulillah i
wasn't because i had him as a role model
and if you want to be the best you have
to look up to the best and the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
was the best of the best and if you want
to be a good man if you want to be the
best man
by the way from the meadow there he had
multiple wives so let me just slip that
in
if you want to be the best of the best
then look towards the best
and may allah make us from the best
aloha
i mean bro and fellas well guys and
girls but
specifically fellas look forward to a
couple case studies we're going to go on
in the near future about the prophet
sallallahu assalam's life is upbringing
we're really going to dissect that
because contrary to what people
have been taught at times he wasn't some
guy that's like
too much on one side of the spectrum
where he was like a pushover he was
nice to everyone didn't have a backbone
but he was also not on the other end of
the spectrum where he was just
savage and didn't have a heart bro he
was the perfect peace be upon a man
that have ever lived in this dunya
no one will compare so it's worth it's
worth uh
going into
fox all right what time is it
243. perfectly all right
we shall end it okay
allah bless the two of you and everybody
for watching thank you for sticking
around may allah bless you immensely and
allow this to be a source of good for
everybody
may allah make us from amongst the best
of the best and from the few who are
actually good aloha i mean
allah
if you made it this far comment down a
little queasy so we know